PROFESSOR: So let's write
the Hamiltonian again
in terms of v and v dagger.
So for this equation, v
dagger v, from this equation,
is equal to 2 h bar over
m omega, a dagger a.
And immediately above
equation v dagger v's, this--
we substitute into
the Hamiltonian.
And Hamiltonian becomes the nice
object h bar omega, a dagger
a plus 1/2 if you want.
All right.
We did this hard work
of factorization.
We have to show what's good for.
Well, in fact, we're
going to be able to solve
the harmonic oscillator
without ever talking
about differential-- almost
ever talking about differential
equations.
In fact, we will not talk about
the second order differential
equation.
Thanks to our
great work here, we
will have to talk about a first
order differential equation,
and a much simpler one.
And only one, not for
and n 1, 2, 3, infitinty,
infinity number of polynomials.
It's a great simplification.
Other Hamiltonians
admit factorization.
In fact, there's whole books
of factorizable Hamiltonians,
because those are the nicest
Hamiltonians to solve.
Let's see why, though.
We haven't said why yet.
Here is the leading
thing that we can do.
Remember we recalled 5
psi the integral dx phi
star of x psi of x.
This is just notation.
So the expectation value,
calculate the expectation value
of the Hamiltonian
in some state psi.
Could be the general state sum.
So what are you supposed to do?
You're supposed to do psi h psi.
This is normalized state,
the expectation value
is the integral
of psi star h psi.
That's what this is.
But now, let's put
in this information.
And the expectation value
of this would be psi h--
or let me do it this way-- h
bar ome-- well, let's go slow.
Psi h omega a dagger a a
psi plus h omega over 2 psi.
So I just calculated
h on psi, and I
wrote what it is-- h
omega this, this term.
So this is two terms--
h omega psi a dagger a psi
plus h omega over 2 psi psi.
OK.
So what did I gain
with the factorization?
So far, it looks like nothing.
But here we go--
this term is equal to 1,
because the wave function
is normalized.
And here I can do one thing--
I can remember my definition
of a Hermitian conjugate.
I can move an operator and
put its Hermitian conjugate
on the other side.
So think of this
operator, a dagger--
a dagger is acting on
this wave function.
What is a dagger?
It's this.
And p is h bar over idex.
So this-- you know how to act.
But if a dagger is here, I
can put it on the first wave
function, but I must put
the dagger of this operator,
and the dagger of a dagger is a.
So this is h omega, a psi
a psi plus h omega over 2.
Now here comes the next thing.
If this is an inner
product, any phi phi
is greater or equal than 0,
because you would have phi star
phi, and that's positive.
So any of that [INAUDIBLE]
is greater or equal than 0.
Note-- here you have
some function, but here
the same function.
It is this case.
That thing is greater
or equal than 0.
That is the great benefit of
the factorized Hamiltonian--
if h has a v dagger v, you
can flip the v dagger here
and it becomes v psi v
psi, and it's positive.
And you've learned
something very important,
and you can get
positive energies.
In fact, from here,
since this is positive,
this must be greater or
equal than h omega over 2.
Because this is greater
than equal than 0.
So the expectation value
of the Hamiltonian--
if you would be thinking
now of energy eigenstates,
the energy eigenvalue
is the expectation value
of the Hamiltonian in
an energy eigenstate
must be greater than
h bar omega over 2.
And in some blackboard
that has been erased,
we remember that the lowest
energy state had energy--
there it is.
The lowest energy state
has energy h omega over 2.
So look at this, and
you say, OK, this
shows that any eigenstate
must have energy
greater than h omega over 2.
But could there be one state
for which the energies exactly
h omega over 2.
Yes, if this inner product is 0.
But for an inner product
of two things to be 0,
each function must be 0.
So from this, we conclude that
if there is a ground state,
it's a state for which a phi--
or a psi is equal to 0.
So this is a very
nice conclusion.
So if the lower
bound is realized,
so that you get a state with
energy equal h bar over 2,
then it must be true
that a psi is equal to 0.
And a psi equal to 0 means x
plus ip over m omega on psi
is equal to 0, or x plus
p is h bar over i ddx,
so this is h bar over m omega
d/dx on psi of x is equal to 0.
And that was the promised fact.
We have turned the second
order differential equation
into a first order
differential equation.
Think of that magic that
has happened to do that.
You had a second order
differential equation
because the Hamiltonian
has x squared b squared.
By factorizing, you go two first
order differential operators.
And by Hermeticity, you
were led to the condition
that the lowest energy
state had to be killed by a.
That's why a is called
the annihilation operator.
It should be killed.
And now you have to solve
a first order differential
equation, which is a game.
An easy game compared with
a second order differential
equation.
So let's, of course, solve it.
It doesn't take any time.
Let's call this
the ground state.
If it exists.
And this gives you d psi 0 v x
is equal to minus m omega over
h bar x psi .
0.
This can be degraded easily
or you can guess the answer.
It's an exponential.
Anything that differentiates
that you should extend
the same function
as an exponential--
e to the minus m omega
2 h squared x squared
is the solution.
Psi 0 of x is equal to
some number times that.
This was-- the number is
the Hermit polynomials
sub 0, and that exponential,
this exponential,
we wrote a few blackboards ago.
It's a good exponential.
It's a perfect Gaussian.
It's our ground state.
And 0, if you want
to normalize it,
m 0 is equal to m omega
over phi h bar to the 1/4.
And that is the ground state.
And it has energy,
h omega over 2.
You could see what
the energy is by doing
this very simple calculation.
Look, get accustomed
to these things.
H hat psi 0.
What is h?
Is h omega a dagger a
plus 1/2 acting on psi 0.
The a acting on psi
0 already kills it.
Because that's the
defining equation.
Well that's 0.
And you get 1/2 h bar omega,
confirming that you did
get this thing to be correct.
So this is only the
beginning of the story.
We found the ground
state, and now we
have to find the excited states.
Let me say a couple
of words to set up
this discussion for next time.
The excited states appear
in a very nice way as well.
So first a tiny bit
of language, of h bar.
This equal h omega,
a dagger a is usually
called the number operator.
We'll explain more
on that next time.
So n number operator
is a dagger a.
It's a permission operator,
and it's pretty much
the Hamiltonian.
It's the number, it's called.
Why is it called the number
is what we have to figure out.
It is a counting operator--
it just looks at the state
and counts things.
So what does this give us?
Well, we also know that
the number operator kills
phi 0, because a kills psi 0.
A kills it.
So that's what we have.
So we did say that
a was a destruction
operator, annihilation
operator, because it annihilates
the ground state.
So if a annihilates
the ground state,
a dagger cannot annihilate
the ground state.
Why?
Because a dagger with a
computator is equal to 1.
Look at this.
This is a a dagger
minus a dagger a.
Act on the ground state.
That's it.
Now this term kills it.
But this term
better not kill it,
because it has to give
you back the ground
state if this is true.
And this is true.
So a dagger doesn't
kill the ground state.
Since it doesn't kill it, it's
called a creation operator.
So you have this
state, but now there's
also this state a dagger
acting on the vacuum.
And there's a state a dagger
a dagger acting on the vacuum.
And all those.
And what we will
figure out next time
is that, yes, this
is the ground state.
And this is the
first excited state.
second excited state.
And goes on forever.
So we'll have a very compact
formula for the excited states
of the harmonic oscillator.
They're just creation
operators acting on the ground
state or the [INAUDIBLE].